welcome to the session master security
and compliance in public clouds my name
is Kristine Chavez and I'm a senior Club
architect with Roger buzzer AG I am
doing this session together with grace
Morrison from Google cloud in the
beginning I would like to give you a
short overview on torch browser cool but
we are so-called market infrastructure
provider and as such technology is
really in our DNA our first fully
automatic electronic trading system was
launched in the light late nineties this
one is operating on lowest latency
networks and technology and together
with our colocation partners we are
operating one of the largest European
financial data centers all our core
business applications are actually self
developed and safe maintained and we do
this was round about 2,000 people in our
team our core is really our trading and
clearing applications as you can see we
use them not only for securities trading
but in the end for any kind of financial
derivatives trading currency trading but
also trading of commodities like energy
in addition dodgeballs group is offering
pre trading services so we calculate we
turn in exists like for example the
ducks and the stocks we also operate
ultra-low latency data feeds for our
customers the post training area is
dealing with settlement and custody
services and in addition we offer
value-added services like investment
fund services or collateral management
everything of this is backed by our
information technology as you can see we
are really a core element of the
European and global capital market and
as such we are a scrutiny of the highest
regulatory supervision not only by the
German regulator but also by regulations
in Luxembourg Switzerland and the UK
torture browser group is using public
cloud as one of the main technologies to
drive our world map 2020 public cloud is
fueling our foundations for other
technologies like for example blockchain
based services we develop and one
blockchain based services for
to assets or digital custody in addition
we leverage public cloud for analyzing
big data sets for of us or of our
customers and we also make use of
machine learning capabilities so as you
can see public cloud is adding a lot of
agility into our mix because with this
we can react dynamically to changing
business demands and you can leverage
new technologies to develop new
solutions for our customers but we use
public cloud also to improve the overall
quality of our systems and this is
achieved by standardization and
automation and by the additional
possibilities which public cloud offer
to us as a good example our core trading
platform called g7 is spinning up every
night hundreds of test instances in
order to conduct some kind of random
tests so-called monkey tests and then
based upon the behavior of this we can
improve the overall quality of course
use public cloud also to reduce your
operational cost by standardization and
automation we are implementing a
so-called nightly cloud hybrid cloud
strategy as you can see on the lower
right corner we are not leveraging only
the Google cloud platform in addition we
team up with all the hypest galas in the
infrastructure as a service and platform
as a service area and also for software
as a service we work together with the
market leaders the mighty cloud strategy
is important to us because it allows us
to select really the best service for
each use case but in addition it also
prevents the vendor lock-in and this is
something which is demanded by the
regulators so whenever we move workloads
into the public cloud we have to provide
a so called exit strategy the exit
strategy could be that we either fall
back to on-premise or that we move the
workload from one public cloud into the
other public cloud in order to do so we
implemented an hybrid approach
leveraging technologies like container
and kubernetes this is allows us to
dynamically shift workloads between
on
promised and the different health
service providers now we know of course
that this is not just on a quick switch
but in the end it's sufficient that we
can prove that within a certain time
frame we can move workloads out of one
cloud and move it back to another one
now let's look into the security aspects
this picture I guess is very familiar to
most of you it outlines the so-called
shared responsibility model from the
lower part you see the responsibilities
of the cloud service provider which deal
with the so-called security of the cloud
this covers typically the data centers
physical Hardware network up to the
hypervisor level but also the cloud
services itself and also the IT
processes in the back things like access
management incident management or
capacity management on top of that you
have the security in the cloud this is
our responsibility as a customer so we
have to make sure that we provide secure
access into the cloud we have to define
appropriate roads you have to define
security guard ways to make sure that we
don't compromise on the high level of
security when we move into the public
cloud typically the lower part is
tackled by looking at external
certifications external reports like ISO
27000 soft to talk to reports and so on
but the regulator Matic crystal clear to
us that only looking at these kind of
certifications and attestation spatter
party providers is not sufficient they
deem the use of cloud services similar
like the classical outsourcing and hence
we need to have the same control
mechanisms in place and one of them is
that we need to have an unrestricted
right to audit that we really can
uncover and look into the details how
the cloud service provider is
implementing all the required security
controls now if we would do this alone
this would mean a lot of effort for us
because as you have seen previously we
work with a lot of different cloud
service provides together and an audit
is typically an
hmm which takes a couple of weeks or
even months and you need a lot of people
in order to do so on the other side this
is also a lot of effort for the cloud
service provider because it's not only
us having this unrestricted right to
audit but in the end or Institute's in
the same area so for example all the
financial service Institute's hence we
came up a couple of years ago with the
idea of a collaborative audit work the
color what if audit group is an open
format where financial service
Institute's jointly together conduct an
audit with the cloud service provider
this has been proven in 2017 the first
time in a small proof of concept then
2018 was wicked very first large-scale
audit conducted and in 2019 also Google
cloud platform was audited by the
collaborative Oracle currently has
around about 40 different financial
service it's accused in the
collaborative audit group but as
mentioned any financial Institute's can
join here for the security in the cloud
part we based our selves on the ISO
27001 framework together with our
information security colleagues we
identified seven focus domains where we
put a lot of effort into implementing
security controls to achieve the high
level of security which we are known for
our on-premise infrastructure as well so
the focused domains are here shaded in
light blue and cover things like asset
management access control cryptography
and so on so we concluded with our
colleagues that we needed 20 different
initiatives in order to implement all
the required controls to cover
dimensionizer domains so as you can see
this is pretty much a mix of where we
extend already existing solutions a good
example is a cyber art for published
access management or where we identified
the cloud negative
services as appropriate for example in
the area of key management and sequence
management sometimes also we identified
that there's neither a solution
on-premise available not a cloud
negative solution available
and we did an evaluation of a new tool a
good example here is aqua sec for
compliance checking of containers in our
kubernetes setup now as you can see
applying security in the cloud is a lot
of effort it's a lot of effort because
when one side there's always new
requirements coming from the regulators
and your security threats out there and
on the other side also the cloud service
providers are always offering new
services and new possibilities but what
we found is that in the end applying
security in the cloud is something which
is the same for every client so it's not
only us doing the configuration during
the security guard where it's
configuration in the world definition
and so on and yet every client at least
under the same regulation has to be do
the same effort and we thought how could
this be made more efficient and the idea
we discussed with Google here is that
the cloud service provider could take
back some part of the responsibility of
the security in the cloud by providing
things like certified landing zones
which are compliant by default and I
think this not only increases the
security posture for the clients and
puts down the barriers of moving really
critical workloads into the cloud we
think this is also increasing the over
security posture for Google and this is
why we came into close discussion with
grace and thankfully now I hand over for
her to continue Thank You Christian so
Christian called out some focus domains
from the 14 control domains in ISO 27001
Google Code cloud is able to provide
great guardrails and controls to address
these with native tooling as well as
being able to integrate partner
solutions to help with implementing the
controls I'm just showing here some
native ways to help meet the
requirements but we have a rich partner
ecosystem they can also help so you can
leverage your existing investment in
those partner solutions today however
I'm going to focus on responding to
these challenges Christian set us how do
we just security in the cloud
for many customers who all have
different business goals and
applications how can we make it
efficient to address how do we clearly
distinguish who does what in a shared
responsibility model and what about
certified landing zones so Christian is
right it's the same challenge for every
customer and taken across sample of the
questions we've been asked you can see
that other customers are asking the same
things
Christian is ask Karen my regulated
workload what products are certified for
the regulation will standard I need to
comply with what do I need to do to
achieve my security posture our
customers they said we also want a
single place to find the assets we need
to address our security posture we
responded with the Google cloud
compliance Resource Center security
health analytics is an exception but
I'll come back to that the compliance
Resource Center is the way to find
Google clouds compliance offerings live
region and Industry with best practices
and documentation to support your
compliance reporting needs you can gain
access to Google cloud attestations
reports to confirm compliance with the
variety of standards and regulations
Google cloud provides a variety of
security guidance to help customers
deploy and develop with the security
first mindset customers can satisfy
themselves and they can reach their
security Krotz requirements by Google
cloud providing guidance and the ability
for customers to implement the
guardrails required we want to provide
prescriptive guidance and easily
deployable assets which we collectively
our security blueprints Christian you
may recall said what about the idea of a
blueprint where the CSP arjen cloud site
service provider takes part of
responsibilities of in the cloud and
also provides certified Lanza's loans
that are combined by before so we do
have security blueprints Google clouds
definition of a blueprint provides a
package of documentation and assets
which can be consumed all stages of the
customer lifecycle the intended users
are folks working the customers
compliance the governance function and
also security administrators they may be
of interest to other users business or
technical to determine for example if
certain use cases are feasible at loop
package varies in size based on
complexity of the use case so Google
Cloud has two types of security
blueprints compliant landing zones for
example gke for PCI and product a
workload vote because such as those to
anthos or for your data like to date the
warehouse pipeline the compliant and
Andean zoned blueprints have more
components than the workload focused
blueprints but both types have the core
components that are the watt which
explains what controls you need and what
you need to do and the how which are the
deploy core assets and instructions the
first compliant landing zone blueprint
published is PCI 4gk a gk is a google
kubernetes engine this has a number of
deployed assets available in a github
repo repo it provides comprehensive
guidance including things like a quick
star prereq so you can configure your
workstation and diagrams and lots of
them no help knowing the issues and
limitations and helpful links our first
product specific blueprint collection is
Ram Dass the first we are published and
we're working on more let's take a
closer look at one of the blueprints in
the collection locality restricted
workloads but first up it give you a
short overview of anthos anthos is an
open a hybrid multi cloud application
platform which it basically is managed
kubernetes for gke
it allows you to run gke where you need
to on Google Cloud on-premises or
another cloud it provides a consistent
way to manage your GP gke clusters in a
secure manner anthos has a security
first approach it provides an auditable
and centralized workflow to deploy
conflict changes which both your
security admins and operations team want
it allows you to enforce compliance and
for service mesh which is a key part of
the anthers platform abstract some of
the lower level security options needed
to secure your micro services with MPLS
and certificate management now this is
an accession on anthos so don't worry if
you don't know what all these things I'm
showing you here are the key thing is
that to be able to configure your anthis
environment to meet your locality
restriction requirements to
forswear your applications are deployed
or where they can be accessed from you
need to consider a number of things such
as where your services are located and
you need to configure a number of other
things to address these considerations
so making this simple prescriptive to
configure is the aim of the security
blueprints to provide prescriptive
guidance to help our customers secure
their applications takes a village it
starts with our customers you know so we
work with our engineering teams UX
designers and tech editor x' to sure
we're delivering guides that are not too
jargon heavy that valide isn't easier to
consume we've in effect we partner with
our customers so the guidance we are
providing is not created in a bubble and
has customer input from the beginning of
the process but we didn't actually stop
at blueprints our customers want to know
what Google Cloud products
compliant with a given standard the
shared responsibility model and what
steps they need to take to configure
those products so they comply so the
Security Command Center is the answer to
that
it's the canonical security and risk
database for Google Cloud it is an
intuitive intelligent restored and
analytic system for services
understanding and remediating Google
Cloud security and data risk across an
organization note though it's not
suitable for it's not a substitute for
audits certification or reports of
compliance of your products or services
with the new regulatory or industry
benchmarks or standards it's a guide to
help you a key feature of the security
command center is security health
analytics in the premium tier it
provides monitoring for many industry
best practices and compliance monitoring
across your Google Cloud assets these
results can also be reviewed in a
compliance dashboard so here's an
example of the security health analytics
dashboard when using the premium tier
it's a single place to view how well
you're mapping against requirements
now the mouthful sorry about this the C
is Google Cloud foundation 1.0 mappings
have been reviewed and certified by the
center for internet security for
alignment for the CIS Google cloud
computing foundations benchmarks V 1.0.0
additional compliance mappings are
included for reference and a lot and
they're not providing or reviewed by PCI
or the Oh apps Foundation and I just
want to reiterate as I said earlier it's
not a substitute for audit certification
or report of compliance of your products
or services that any regulatory or
industry benchmarks or standard still
looking at the security health analytics
from the findings page you can click on
the category and we'll provide guidance
as to what you need to do to remedio
okay so it's a powerful tool to help you
so I just want to kind of bring it all
together and talk about the user journey
to use the these these tools that I've
talked about you've just heard what
Google cloud have done in response to
our customers request to make it easier
by providing the compliance Resource
Center as the place to go
customers have many personas involved
involved in ensuring that they meet
their compliance security security
requirements so I just want to summarize
by walk you through a typical customers
journey through the compliance Resource
Center showing how the various personas
interact with it so it normally starts
with the C so in many cases who wants to
check that Google Cloud can meet the
desired compliance regime and maybe
validation at this stage what products
are in scope if that gets the okay then
the security admins and architects start
looking at what Google Cloud could be
used for and the configuration they need
to be by using the compliance map
security health analytics and the
blueprints and then the platform
operations security admins and Ed's
knowing what security postures need to
be met can use the security health
analytics and blueprints to achieve that
when they configure their environments
and deploy their applications so
everyone in the journey to meet your
compliance and security posture are
using the same route same assets so
thank you thank you for listening and I
hope that was a some use